in today's video we'll continue learning
a beautiful 400 year old loot piece that
you can play on your guitar it's called
Mr dowelin's midnight and it sounds like
this
[Music]
make sure you've watched part one if you
haven't already as well as my other
videos on the history of tablature now
without further Ado here is part two
in terms of the tempo of this piece
let's not forget the title Mr dowland
that's the composer of the piece he's
referring to himself midnight so what
does Midnight represent Darkness
depression the absence of Light which is
good and darkness which can be haunting
and scary so maybe loneliness being
afraid something sad so being a sad
piece like this I think this sort of
represents Darwin's Melancholy in fact
Donald was famous for writing
melancholic music like the famous flow
my tears for example
[Music]
when the noise
so in playing this piece I'd encourage
you to keep a nice slow tempo it doesn't
have to go fast because the slow speed
can sound more more melancholic in fact
slow and quiet together make a nice
melancholic sound
[Music]
foreign
we just have to talk about the Rhythm
and then these little dots that we see
throughout the piece in tablature the
rhythm is located above the lines and we
see these flags represent different with
nickel values very much like modern
score we have an eighth note that has a
little flag on it this is kind of like
that now historically these have
specific names like minims and
semi-minums for the sake of ease in this
introductory lesson I just want to say
we're going to simplify a little bit to
use modern language and make this make
sense we're going to think of these
notes as quarter notes so those are two
chord notes the first chord would be a
dotted quarter note and the second note
would be an eighth note you'll notice
actually in this piece most of the notes
are just quarter notes so if we're
thinking in 4 4 most the time we play
one two three four
just occasionally we have to do
something else either eighth notes or a
dotted quarter note so to understand the
first bar I like to think one and two
and three and four end the dotted
quarter note gets one and two
one and two the next eighth note appears
on the end of two so one and two and and
then the next two are easy three and
four and so one and two and three and
four and now I'll do it again but
without me actually counting ready go
foreign
but in your mind if you think one and
two and three and four and it'll give
you the right proportion the second
measure has an easy Rhythm it's just
quarter quarter quarter quarter so
One Beat each the third measure rhythm
is the same as the first one two and
three and four and
and the fourth measure is easy one two
three and there's nothing on before
that's called the half note when you
have a chord last for two beats three
four that's a half note now in the
manuscript the things you see that have
three beams these we can think of as
eighth notes in other words that one and
two and three and each of those things
I'm counting one then two and three and
are eighth notes so if we look at
measure eight we see one and two and
three four
so we see four fast notes eighth notes
and one long half note one and two and
three four
in other words in each measure you count
up to four just listen to my recording
or me playing for now to get a sense of
how it's supposed to go
now before we call it a day the last me
to know it's very simple you see dots
under certain notes the dots as we
learned in my history of tablature video
in this case they refer to the right
hand fingering so one dot under a note
means we should pluck it with your index
finger two dots means you should pluck
it with your middle finger it's very
common in this period to play scales
with the thumb and index finger so thumb
index thumb index thumb index thumb
index
kind of like a pick in fact that's where
the technique comes from playing with a
pick
it's actually very fast
so now I'm going to play the piece and I
want you to watch my right hand and to
get a sense for playing the index finger
and the thumb whenever possible on
strong beats to get that sense of weak
beats and strong beats good notes and
bad notes that we talked about in the
previous video
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
if you're enjoying this free lesson and
are serious about improving on guitar
I'd highly encourage you to check out my
online music school rpajato this is an
online school for plucked instruments
and if you'd like to learn a plucked
instrument like Guitar ukulele bass loot
or more or delve deeper into the subject
of tablature we have an assortment of
specialists in various instruments and
styles who can give you weekly lessons
on Zoom so please check out arpajato.com
to learn more you'll notice that the
thumb pops down and plays a lot of the
second and the first string
this is normal in Renaissance Loop music
and gives us an really nice sense of
strong weak strong weeds to wrong wheat
strong weak strong week strong week
strong as opposed to
[Music]
which sounds clumsy
congratulations at this point you
officially know everything you need to
know to play this piece from a 400 year
old manuscript now this piece comes from
an entire book of pieces in the same
handwriting I'll include a link to that
book in the description and there are
countless more books just like that
available for free on websites like
imslp.org at this point you should
practice this notation more get used to
this piece get really good at it and
then once you feel comfortable start
exploring that book and discovering this
music for the first time there's
hundreds and hundreds of years of music
just sitting there waiting for you to
play it if you enjoyed today's video
make sure you subscribe and hit the Bell
so you don't miss other videos I post
like this one if you want to help me
make more videos like this you can go to
my patreon and there you'll find lots of
behind the scenes content about what I'm
up to the videos I'm making performances
I'm giving and you'll receive rewards
like early viewing all my videos my CDs
and you can even get a private lesson
with me and lastly if you're interested
in learning the classical guitar
especially at your own pace at home I
have a beginner online classical guitar
course called classical guitar Pro it's
six hours long 53 videos so I hope
you'll check that out until next time
thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you